Así es muy buenas tardes a Raúl pues
efectivamente esa Victoria INE extremis
de Irán sobre gales en un partido en el
que venían de tú a tú y finalmente Pues
fue un primer error por parte de la
defensa de gales la que dio la
posibilidad para que pudiera marcar ese
primer gol en el minuto 98 ya y luego
prácticamente casi que un minuto y medio
vendría ese segundo tanto de ramin pues
dando esa Liberación a Irán que de esta
manera pues continúa con vida en este
mundial pone las cosas bastante
complicadas para los el capitaneados por
Gareth Bale porque finalmente se ven
obligados a ganarle a Inglaterra en el
próximo partido para poderse mantener
con vida y pues vamos a ver esta noche
qué pasa Porque Inglaterra juega ante
Estados Unidos una Duelo 100% anglosajón
Así es hablemos ahora a Natalia de la
selección de Brasil y la preocupación
por la lesión de Neymar en su tobillo
vimos las imágenes que le dieron la
vuelta al mundo del tobillo
completamente totalmente hinchado no
después de este partido Durante este
partido
Así es una dolorosa imagen bastante
inflamado ese tobillo Pero bueno son
lesiones a las que el Astro brasilero ya
nos tiene acostumbrados porque siempre
ha tenido digamos Esa esa dolencia o esa
falencia física en todo caso a pesar de
que ya lo vimos pues Incluso en imágenes
cogiendo cuando iba por la zona mixta en
la noche de ayer después de el partido
ante Serbia pues Por ahora se sabe es
que el médico de la selección Pues es lo
tienen en fisioterapia aplicaron y se
estaba mirando si se le iba a hacer o no
una resonancia el día de hoy pero decían
que había que esperar por lo menos unos
24 o 48 horas para poder tener digamos
un diagnóstico más más preciso de esta
situación a pesar de que hay algunos
medios que ya dicen que Neymar no
jugaría en el próximo partido y que
muchísimo menos estaré allá en el último
que es contra Cameron pues la federación
a brasilera hace unos ratos nos dijo que
Eh Pues por ahora no han una
confirmación de ninguna lesión de Neymar
Así que Seguiremos esperando